Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Quand on parle des Gaulois,
je suis sûr que la première image qui vous vient
à l'esprit, c'est
C'est celle d'un guerrier avec des tresses blondes,
une grosse moustache et un casque surmonté de deux ailes.
Sans lunettes, évidemment.
Mais cette image d'Épinal correspond-elle à la réalité ?
Les Gaulois étaient ils aussi indisciplinés qu'on le prétend ?
Analphabètes et bagarreurs ?
Avec l'irréductible Thibault, de la chaîne Histoire Appliquée,
nous faisons aujourd'hui la part du vrai et du faux
sur cette idée fixe à propos de nos fameux ancêtres.
C'est vrai que nous avons énormément d'idées reçues sur les Gaulois.
Regardez, j'ai dressé ici
une liste de tous les clichés qui leur collent à la peau.
Et oui, effectivement, elle est longue comme mon bras.
Parmi les clichés les plus répandus, il y a bien sûr
leur apparence physique.
Les grosses moustaches
les cheveux longs, les cheveux blonds, les tresses.
Pourtant, chez les Gaulois,
les hommes ne portaient pas tous la moustache et ils n'avaient pas
tous des cheveux longs et encore moins gras.
À l'époque,
comme c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui,
le look était fonction de la mode du moment et du groupe
auquel on appartenait.
La Gaule n'était pas uniforme.
Elle était constituée de différents peuples d'origine celtique,
mais qui n'obéissent pas tous aux mêmes codes.
Les Gaulois faisaient donc très attention à leur apparence.
Les Romains eux mêmes les décrivent d'ailleurs
comme des gens très soucieux de leur hygiène et de leurs vêtements.
Ils n'hésitaient d'ailleurs pas à porter de riches bijoux en or
ou en bronze.
Ils auraient même inventé le savon solide tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui.
Vous le voyez, l'image que nous nous faisons des Gaulois est un mythe.
Créé de toutes pièces par les auteurs du XIXᵉ siècle,
qui ont largement participé à colporter une image tronquée de ce peuple.
Des rustres, vivants retranchés dans leurs huttes rudimentaires au cœur des forêts.
Alors que non,
les Gaulois ne vivaient pas dans des huttes faites de bric et de broc.
Les fouilles archéologiques ont montré qu'ils construisaient
de vraies maisons aux formes très variées,
rectangulaires, rondes, ou carrées.
Le plus souvent, ces maisons étaient faites de bois ou de terre.
Dans certaines régions, comme dans le sud,
on y trouvait aussi de la pierre, mais c'était beaucoup plus rare
le toit était recouvert de chaume, de tuiles ou de bois.
Certains Gaulois vivaient à la campagne
dans de petites fermes
ou regroupés dans de grandes exploitations.
Mais aussi surprenant que cela puisse paraître,
la grande majorité vivait en ville
de grandes villes fortifiées que l'on appelle des "oppida".
Un "oppidum" des "oppida".
Parmi les plus célèbres, il y a Alésia ou Bibracte
en Bourgogne, ou encore Gergovie en Auvergne.
Autrement dit, les Gaulois aimaient autant la ville que les Romains.
Regardez, je vous ai amené une armée gauloise reconstituée,
plus précisément une épée gauloise.
L'épée des Gaulois n'est pas très différente du glaive romain.
D'ailleurs, le mot glaive vient du latin "gladius",
qui vient du gaulois "gladio" qui veut dire épée.
Les Gaulois, dit-on, ne s'en séparaient jamais
car ils passaient leur temps à se bagarrer entre eux.
Alors, vrai ? Faux ?
Un peu des deux.
Je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
les Gaulois ne formaient pas une nation unie,
mais un ensemble de peuples qui occupaient le territoire
et partageaient la même culture, à la fois celte et gauloise.
Il en existait plusieurs dizaines, regroupés en territoires
assez autonomes,
comme les Bituriges du côté de Bourges,
les Sénons en Sologne ou les Arvernes en Auvergne.
Cet ensemble était cohérent d'un point de vue culturel,
mais les Gaulois
n'étaient pas du tout unifiés d'un point de vue politique.
Ils n'ont pas un chef unique ni de gouvernement commun,
comme peuvent l'avoir les Romains.
Entre les guerres sont donc assez fréquentes.
On s'embrouille, on s'allie en fonction des intérêts de chacun.
Durant, la guerre des Gaules, par exemple,
il n'est pas rare
qu'un peuple s'allie avec un autre peuple contre un troisième.
Et puis finalement, pour telle ou telle raison, ils vont devenir ennemis
avant de se réconcilier à nouveau contre Rome par exemple.
Parce qu'ils entrent en conflit,
Ces guerriers ne se battent pas du tout de manière
totalement anarchique,
comme on le voit dans les aventures d'Astérix.
Bien au contraire, les Gaulois excellent sur le champ de bataille
et terrifient leurs ennemis par leur célèbre tumulte gaulois.
Ils sont structurés, très organisés, avec une hiérarchie
qui est bien installée.
Grosse différence avec les Romains.
C'est que les armées gauloises ne sont globalement pas
des armées de métier.
Mises à part quelques troupes d'élite,
les soldats sont recrutés dans la population civile,
et en période de paix,
ces combattants occasionnels sont agriculteurs, artisans, commerçants.
Une fois de plus, nous sommes très loin de l'idée
reçue du Gaulois réfractaire, rustre et gros mangeur de sanglier.
À propos de sanglier, je vais sans doute décevoir les fans d'Obélix.
Les Gaulois n'en consommaient pas.
On ne trouve quasiment aucun reste de sanglier
dans les déchets culinaires sur les sites archéologiques.
Il faut dire que nos ancêtres avaient une bonne raison de ne pas en consommer.
Chez eux, le sanglier était un animal sacré qui appartenait à la forêt,
donc aux dieux.
Selon la légende, lorsqu'un Gaulois en tuait un, il devait le rembourser
à la nature en sacrifiant l'une de ses propres bêtes.
Enfin bon, c'est une légende.
En revanche, ce qui est sûr, c'est que la viande
faisait bien partie de leur régime alimentaire,
mais elle provenait principalement de l'élevage
En effet,
les Gaulois pratiquent l'élevage de bœuf, de moutons, de chèvres et de porcs.
Ce sont aussi d'habiles cultivateurs
qui occupent un territoire qui n'est
absolument pas couvert de forêts comme on l'imagine,
mais surtout constitué de zones agricoles bien entretenues.
Les terres y sont fertiles.
On y cultive de nombreuses céréales
comme le blé et l'orge, ainsi que des lentilles et des légumes.
Ce sont aussi d'excellents artisans :
des bijoux, des armes, des tissus, des outils.
Les produits qu'ils fabriquent jouissent d'une excellente réputation
et s'exportent dans une bonne partie de l'Europe, y compris à Rome.
C'est l'occasion de tordre le cou à un autre mythe très tenace.
Si les Gaulois fabriquaient de nombreux objets d'art.
En revanche,
ils ne taillaient pas les menhirs.
Absolument pas.
Ces gros blocs de pierre
ont été érigés au néolithique entre 2000 et 5000 ans avant Jésus-Christ,
donc bien avant leur arrivée.
Ce qui signifie que nous sommes deux fois plus proche
du célèbre Vercingétorix, qu'il ne l'est lui même
des hommes qui ont fabriqué les menhirs de Carnac en Bretagne.
C'est quand même dingue, toutes ces idées reçues.
Tiens, encore une qui a la peau dure.
Dans l'inconscient collectif, les Gaulois ne maîtrisaient pas l'écriture.
Eh bien, c'est complètement faux.
Ils ont au contraire laissé un grand nombre de traces écrites.
Les premières inscriptions gauloises datent du IIᵉ siècle
avant Jésus-Christ, bien avant donc l'avènement de Jules César.
Elles ont été découvertes en Provence et en Bourgogne.
Elles portent en grande partie sur des noms propres gravés
sur des pierres tombales, des cruches ou des bols.
D'autres font parfois référence à des échanges commerciaux.
Les Gaulois écrivaient en langue gauloise,
mais ils utilisaient l'alphabet grec ou latin.
Ce cliché du gaulois analphabète
vient d'une mauvaise lecture d'un passage de la Guerre des Gaules.
Dans ce bouquin, César rapporte que les druides, qui voulaient
conserver le secret de leur pratique, évitent l'usage de l'écriture.
Pourtant, dans ce même passage, il est aussi mentionné
que les Gaulois écrivent pour les affaires courantes.
Thibault, qu'est-ce que tu regardes ?
Je ne sais pas...
C'est le plafond...
Je n'ai pas tellement confiance.
J'ai l'impression qu'il va me tomber sur la tête.
Si vous avez lu les aventures d'Astérix,
vous connaissez cette célèbre réplique.
"Les Gaulois n'ont peur que d'une chose que le ciel
leur tombe sur la tête."
Vous pensez peut être qu'elle a été inventée de toutes pièces
par les auteurs de la bande dessinée ?
Eh bien, il n'en est rien.
En réalité, cette histoire date d'Alexandre le Grand, c'est-à-dire
bien avant Astérix.
Alexandre le Grand Conquérant,
a entendu parler des Gaulois de ses farouches combattants.
Il a envie de les rencontrer et les invite à un grand banquet.
La fête bat son plein.
Tout le monde est un peu éméché et Alexandre leur demande
alors :
"Qu'est ce que vous craignez le plus ?"
Le conquérant ici s'attend à ce que les Gaulois disent :
"Eh bien, on craint les armées d'Alexandre."
Mais les Gaulois répondent alors qu'ils ne craignent qu'une seule chose
que le ciel leur tombe sur la tête.
Alexandre est un peu étonné
mais trouve que les Gaulois sont finalement bien courageux.
La célèbre phrase vient tout simplement de là.
En tout cas,
ce n'est pas pour se protéger du ciel qui tombe sur la tête
que les Gaulois
portaient des casques,
mais bien pour se protéger la tête sur le champ de bataille.
Vous êtes peut-être un peu surpris par celui que je porte ?
Eh bien, effectivement, il n'a pas d'ailes. Pas du tout.
Rien à voir avec celui d'Astérix, ni même avec celui de Vercingétorix.
Tel qu'on le représente sur les gravures.
Cette erreur nous vient de dessins réalisés à la suite
des fouilles archéologiques au XIXᵉ siècle.
A cette époque, on avait mis la main sur des casques gaulois très abîmés.
On a donc eu des difficultés
à mettre au point des dessins clairs et précis.
Alors on a un peu improvisé en dessinant
ce qui pouvait s'apparenter à des ailettes,
mais qui étaient en fait des paragnathides.
Vous savez, c'est ce qui servait à protéger les joues
sur certains types de casques antiques.
En réalité, la plupart des casques gaulois étaient assez lisses,
comme le mien.
Un casque lisse dévie mieux les coups
et il est aussi beaucoup plus simple à fabriquer.
Il reste que certains casques, probablement destinés aux officiers,
portent des ornements à base de plumes ou de crin de cheval.
Exactement comme celui ci.
Ça les rendait plus visibles pour leurs hommes durant le combat.
Les Gaulois fabriquaient aussi
parfois des casques qui pourraient vous sembler très amusants,
mais dont l'usage était probablement réservé à des rituels
et non aux combats.
Citons par exemple ces deux casques impressionnants
retrouvés dans le sanctuaire de Tintignac, en Corrèze.
L'un est affublé d'un grand col de cygne, l'autre de trois anneaux,
qui sont réputés inutilisables au combat
car bien trop lourds et déséquilibrés.
Enfin, et je sais que vous l'attendiez, est-ce qu'il est possible
qu'il y ait eu
un village d'irréductibles Gaulois
qui a résisté encore et toujours à l'envahisseur ?
Difficile à dire, même s'il est bien resté quelques villes et villages
qui ont résisté aux Romains
bien après Alésia, comme la ville d'Uxellodunum,
dans les environs de Cahors.
Malheureusement, sans potion magique,
ces défenseurs furent vaincus et subirent un triste sort pour l'exemple.
La Gaule devient alors une des provinces les plus solides de l'Empire romain,
parce qu'en réalité, ce gouvernement romain
n'a pas vraiment changé le quotidien des Gaulois,
à part stopper définitivement les conflits
entre les peuples de la Gaule, bien évidemment.
Merci Thibault. C'était passionnant.
Une gorgée de savoir,
c'est aussi efficace contre les idées reçues
que la potion magique contre les Romains.
Et puis, si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce bleu ou à vous abonner.
Et surtout, indiquez-moi en commentaire les sujets Histoire
que vous aimeriez que l'on traite.
Panoramix, c'est vide.